[Music]
welcome to travel dares I'm Joe and I'm
Caroline we love to travel together but
have completely different interests we
are going to cities across America and
walking blindfolded into activities that
will take us far out of our comfort
zones in this episode we're taking on
New York City I'm taking Caroline to
brick lane curry house to try some of
the spiciest curry in New York City and
I'm taking Joe to body by Brooklyn where
he's gonna try their top at massage
come join us on our adventures on this
episode of Travel dares hey welcome to
travel there's my name is Joe and I'm
Caroline and we're here in New York City
the greatest city in the world there's
people this energy this food there's
music I love it there's no other city in
the world like this how excited are you
for your adventure that we're excited I
have no idea what it is but I'm ready
for it here it is
clue number one get ready to sweat okay
nope on a scale of one to ten how
excited are you solid ten I think this
place is gonna be great for Caroline she
doesn't do too well with spicy food but
I think she's trying to get better and I
think this restaurants gonna be perfect
for that
Oh check it out that my friend is some
of the spiciest curry in
[Music]
all right Caroline now before we eat I
want to take you back in the kitchen and
show you how they make the spicy curry
sounds good in order to be in the
presence of this dish being made you
have to wear a gas mask oh I'm going to
give you this one and I'm gonna go all
the way back here follow something that
actually was not started in there it was
something that started in England so
when we were trying to do it here in New
York I said well you know what might as
well do it the right way we sort of
claim that we are the spices carrying
the world people do come from I could
say all over the world
[Music]
and spicy it's spicy yeah oh it really
hurts
oh man beside of being like this Pisces
thing ever eat and it's also so
flavorful and I'm starting to lose
feeling up my tongue I'm going in for
more hey that's like a lot no it's good
I I always thought I didn't like spicy
food but I'm doing really well yeah I
gotta say this is the spiciest curry
I've ever had about you this is a
spiciest and most delicious curry I've
ever had New York is the center of food
from all over the world and I want to
come back and like try all the other
curries on the venue you know I guess
that's the point of travel to get out of
your comfort zone go to new cities and
try new experiences
cheers Cheers I feel it yeah oh no it's
fine thank you for taking me there I'm
excited for you to experience your
activity it's a gonna be done said it on
senses prepare for a sugar rush whoa I'm
really excited to take Joe here because
he's never been to a spa but I'm really
excited for him to step outside of his
comfort zone
just put your arm out what is that like
an animal licking my hand yeah go for it
oh look what is that it looks like well
it's a chocolate correct we've been
doing chocolate before I'd say well over
10 years it's been very successful
it feels really almost like silk how
does the chocolate feel it was really
great right
[Music]
chocolate is definitely our most popular
treatment it's hydrating it's an
antioxidant and it's great for cons in
your skin the only thing is you can't
eat it people try to eat the chocolate
all the time and and something I've had
one guy who tried to lick himself if
you're around someone that likes
chocolate they're going to want to be
sniffing you for the rest of the day as
someone who's not used to the spa
experience I feel that this was a
perfect gateway spa experience if that
makes sense you know after this one I
want to do a lot more of them chocolate
spa done yeah
let's give each other a grade out of
five out of five stars how well do you
think I did with my spicy curry job
absolutely a fine yeah I mean it took
her there be like she's gonna flip out
when she sees this we just got in there
you ate almost all of it they did more
than I did I also tried to make it a
point to try different foods that I
wouldn't try out well a scale of 1 to 5
how did I do with my first spa
experience
you were tenth in the beginning and then
I look to my right and I see you like
giggling and that's that made me feel
really happy I would give you a 4 out of
5 only because you're a little nervous
in the beginning but then you kind of
warmed up into fair enough so maybe next
time you'll you'll get that less talk
about getting out of my comfort zone I
never thought I'd be getting a massage
so let alone one covered in chocolate
I can't wait to keep traveling and
discovering all these new places and
just seeing the whole country together
absolutely blast
can't wait
[Music]